le département et antenne réunion vous
présente lien social
[Musique]
la fête de la nature est un événement
national dont l'objectif est de
sensibiliser et faire découvrir le
patrimoine naturel à la réunion cet
événement est soutenu par le conseil
départemental gestionnaire de 95% des
forêts de l'île dans les forêts de l'est
ou sur les hauteurs de saint pierre
thierry et tommy font partager leur
passion et leur quotidien au coeur de
ces espaces naturels sensibles
[Musique]
dernière mise au point pour les
randonneurs avant de s'enfoncer dans les
bois ce matin thierry va guider un
groupe de visiteurs à travers la forêt
d'éden liberia à bras panon
au programme découverte des spécificités
de cet espace naturel sensible vous fait
penser à quoi ce fut mieux des piments
son nom c'est effectivement woippy mon
car aujourd'hui les fruits les arbres et
les fleurs sont à l'honneur à l'occasion
de la 11e fête de la nature le but c'est
de faire découvrir les espaces naturels
sensibles du département au plus grand
nombre de
de visiteurs donc c'est visible à son
gratuit
vous tombez en gras mal de plans qui
sont endémiques et indigènes
on a aussi balayé les fameux lézard vert
qu'il faut protéger le petit lézard vert
que tout le monde guette le voici
fels uma bord monica retenez que celui
là il est endémique de la réunion rare
et discret aussi malgré les paires
d'yeux qui scrute les feuillages le
petit lézard n'a pas daigné montrer le
bout de sa queue mais la forêt abrite
d'autres habitants et au détour du
sentier
les visiteurs découvrent l'un d'entre
eux venait voir et le mal il n'est pas
plus rock ça c'est pas fini car il y a
beaucoup de découvertes à faire dans un
site comme celui ci où même la plus
petite graine peut cacher un trésor
faune flore et fragments d'histoires
aussi nichée au milieu des arbres
quelques teillé témoin d'une ancienne
exploitation dans cette partie de l'île
si vous vous rapprochez venez voir et si
cette randonnée instructive a de quoi
mettre en appétit
c'est bon le goyavier avant de se
remplir l'estomac
les visiteurs vont en prendre plein les
yeux allez on continue
maintenant je vous emmène au paradis
c'est sur un panoramique de l'est de
l'île que la visite s'achève à bras
panon dans le sud
autre point de vue pour d'autres curieux
rencontre voilà et vous voyez le cap de
petite île en bas tommy est l'un des
guides qui s'occupe de l'espace naturel
sensible de python montvert nous avons
le bois de stocks a fait ce qui tourne
nous avons le bois de ce taux est le
bois de stocks a fait et le stock a fait
bon pour faire plus simple reconnaître
la neige le principal et orange est un
peu quand evans soleil elle a fait
beaucoup plus épaisse la fête de la
nature
c'est aussi l'occasion pour les
visiteurs d'apprécier le travail annuel
des équipes de terrain je sais
touristique j'accompagne les gens sur
sur le sentier pour le présenter les
âmes pour présenter mon métier ce que je
fais au quotidien ici marche pas sur les
pieds à risque et les personnes ont
construit si tu marches dessus ça se
casse de notre site nous a pas une très
grande notoriété
donc là avec les manifestations comme ça
c'est bénéfique pour nous et pour le
site aussi donc les gens vont apprendre
à mieux connaître
ben déjà c'est ce que cnn est donc un
espace naturel sensible
ils vont pouvoir voir aussi plusieurs
espèces endémiques indigènes savoir ce
que ça veut dire savoir ce qu'il faut
faire ou ne pas faire dans une forêt qui
visiteront plus tard car derrière la
beauté naturelle peut se cacher un
poison mortel
c'est le cas du bois de remparts est
foutu un boeuf
voilà mais l'utilisé aussi dans dans la
pharmacopée un vu les gens qui ont des
problèmes de peau mais à faible dose
côté faune pas de lézard vert à
l'horizon mais un autre représentant des
reptiles locaux au sol tommy repère les
traces d'un petit mammifère que même les
enfants connaissent bien les folies
tient donc ses les tanks qui font en les
petits qui foule comme ça ils cherchent
les racines petites bêtes et ou pour
manger pour élise charline et leurs
mamans
la fête de la nature c'est aussi
l'occasion de découvrir en famille les
joyaux naturels qui se cache près de
chez elle ben c'était pas très loin de
chez nous donc c'était l'occasion de
voir des endroits qu'on connaît pas
encore à proximité
c'est un stage laquelle on a envie de
toucher à tout
au moins on leur apprend ce qu'il faut
faire ou pas et puis comme elles ont
envie d'apprendre plein de choses c'est
l'occasion parce qu'il ya des racines
qu'est ce qui fait que ça repousse un
nouveau savoir pour les grands aussi les
visites attire toutes les générations
car il n'y a pas d'âge pour
s'émerveiller depuis 20 ans le
département met en oeuvre une politique
de conservation de son patrimoine
naturel la fête de la nature c'est
l'occasion de rassembler le public
autour de la beauté précaire de ce
patrimoine
l'objectif est bien sûr de partager un
moment convivial avec toutes les
personnes qui sont intéressées pour
découvrir les espaces naturels sensibles
il faut savoir que nous sommes 25 sites
qui sont mobilisés donc des
gestionnaires qui partage avec le public
leur savoir faire leur connaissance
c'est un moyen de sensibiliser les gens
d'éduquer les gens et de leur dire que
nous avons la chance d'habiter une île
qui est magnifique qui est un véritable
sanctuaire et qu'il faut donc préserver
cette nature la biodiversité que nous
avons la chance d'avoir et qui est
classée au 34e spot mondiale de la
biodiversité mondiale
avec pour thème cette année les super
pouvoirs de la nature cette 11e édition
de la fête de la nature regrouper 32
super pouvoirs au travers de soixante
dix huit animations pédagogiques
réparties sur 25 sites à travers toute
l'île propriétaire de 95% des forêts de
l'île
le conseil départemental mène depuis
plus de vingt ans une politique de
protection de ses cent mille hectares
d'espacés naturels afin de protéger
l'écosystème de lille le département
consacre chaque année 10 millions
d'euros à de multiples actions de
préservation et de sensibilisation du
public
pour plus de renseignements vous pouvez
consulter le site du département au
www.cegedim.fr
[Musique]